movies that we're collecting in my head  for all the movies I saw I never saw  them I saw a flash of them I saw a movie  that would have a scene that would be  the aesthetic that I was looking for or  they would play a song in a movie and  that would be the kind of song that I  would use and it would have the kind of  feeling that I'd want a song to have in  one of my movies uh or a character would  be the kind of character that I wanted  to do a movie about not all the other  characters just one character you know  but usually like I said it was a scene  it was a a mood for only a little bit or  a section of the movie but it was never  the whole enchilada it was never that  aesthetic that was in my head was never  just there I mean if it was just there  if two or three other people were doing  it I might have been a filmmaker because  I didn't need to get it out of my head